thank you so much hey I'm CMC
well welcome to the White House
everybody
I know I know you have to come here
before you go buy some shovels and some
salt maybe it sounds like we may get a
little snow but but I very much
appreciate everybody being here i want
to thank first and foremost the workers
who are with me here this afternoon
and I want to thank two champions for
all hardworking Americans we've got
Secretary of Labor Tom Perez first time
right here Tom's ready I didn't know
where he was and we've got outstanding
congressman who is used to snow because
he's from minnesota congressman keith
Ellison now it's been just over two
weeks since I delivered my State of the
Union address and I said this year would
be a year of action and I meant it over
the past 14 days I've ordered an
across-the-board reform of our job
training programs to Train folks with
the skills that employers need and then
match them up with good jobs that are
ready to be filled right now I directed
the Treasury to create something we're
calling my are a sort of like an IRA but
it's my RA and that's a new way for
Americans to start saving for retirement
and you can start with as little as
twenty five fifty dollars and start
building up a little bit of a nest egg
and get tax benefits for doing so we've
rallied the leaders of some of America's
biggest high-tech companies to help us
make sure that all of our kids have
access to high speed internet and
up-to-date technology in their
classrooms so that they're learning the
skills that they need for the new
economy we brought together business
leaders who are committed to hiring more
unemployed Americans particularly the
long-term unemployed who oftentimes are
discriminated against yeah they're in a
catch-22 they haven't had a job for a
while and then the employer is not
willing to look at the resume because
they haven't had the job for a while so
the point is I'm eager to work with
Congress whenever I can find
opportunities to expand opportunity for
more families but wherever I can act on
my own without Congress by using my pen
to take executive actions
or picking up the phone and rallying
folks around a common cause that's what
I'm going to do and
and so that brings me the issue we're
going to talk about today after the
worst economic crisis in generations our
economy has been growing for the past
four years and our of businesses have
created eight and a half million new
jobs unemployment rate has come down but
while those at the top are doing better
than ever corporate profits have been
high stock market has been high average
wages have barely budged so you've got
too many Americans who are working
harder than ever before just to get by
but they can't seem to get ahead can't
seem to make all the ends meet and
that's been true since long before the
recession hit we've got to reverse those
trends we've got to build an economy
that works for everybody not just the
fortunate few and we've got to restore
opportunity for everybody so that no
matter who you are no matter how you
started out no matter what you look like
no matter what your last name is you can
get head in America if you're willing to
work hard and take responsibility for
your life right so
so the opportunity agenda I've laid out
is going to help us do just that part 1
of this agenda is more new jobs that pay
a good wage jobs in manufacturing and
exports and energy and innovation part 2
we've got to train the folks with the
skills to fill those jobs part 3 we've
got to make sure every child gets a
world-class education and part 4 we've
got to make sure that the economy
rewards hard work for every American
making hard work pay off with Economic
Security and decent wages and benefits
is what we're about here today it means
making sure women earn equal pay for
equal work
it means making sure workers have the
chance to save for a dignified
retirement it means it means access to
affordable health insurance that gives
you the freedom to change jobs or be
your own boss and a peace of mind
that'll be there for you when you get
sick and you need it most so if you know
anybody who doesn't have health
insurance right now senator healthcare
gov websites working sign them up you
can get health care for less than your
cell phone bill for a lot of folks but
it also means that in the wealthiest
nation on earth nobody who works
full-time should have to live in poverty
nobody
now it was one year ago today one year
ago today that I first asked Congress to
raise the federal minimum wage a federal
minimum wage that in real terms is worth
about twenty percent less than it was
when ronald reagan took office twenty
percent less a fifth less so this
afternoon I've invited some of the folks
who would see a raise if we raise that
federal minimum wage they happen to join
me here at the White House and like most
workers in their situation they're not
teenagers they look like teenagers some
of them are very young looking but
they're not teenagers taking on their
first job they're adults average age is
35 years old a majority of lower-wage
jobs are held by women many of them have
children that they're supporting these
are Americans who work full-time often
to support a family and if the minimum
wage had kept pace with our economic
productivity they'd already be getting
paid well over ten dollars an hour
instead the minimum wage is still just
725 and when Congress refuses to raise
it it loses value because there's a
little bit of inflation everything else
starts costing a little bit more even
though inflation has been pretty low
it's still costing a little bit more
each year that means each dollar isn't
going as far and they've got a little
bit less so over the past year the
failure of Congress to act was the
equivalent of a two-hundred-dollar pay
cut for these folks for a typical
minimum-wage worker that's a month worth
of groceries maybe two months worth of
electricity it makes a big difference
for a lot of families now the good news
is that in the years since I first asked
Congress to raise the minimum wage six
states went ahead and passed laws to
raise theirs
we push it down
you got more states and cities and
counties that are taking steps to raise
their minimum wage as we speak and you
know a lot of companies are doing it too
not out of charity but because they've
discovered it's good business two weeks
ago I visited a costco store in maryland
now costco is a very profitable company
its stock has done great it's expanded
all over the place but their philosophy
is higher wages are a spark way to boost
productivity and reduce turnover if
employees are happy and feel like the
company is invested in them then they're
going to do more for the company they're
going to go above and beyond and and you
know when I was over at the costco store
I was meaning folks who started off as
at the cash register and you know now
we're in supervisory positions and had
been there for 20 years and you could
see the kind of pride that they had in
the company because the company cared
about them I even received a letter the
next day from a woman who saw my visit
on TV she decided to apply a job for
costco she said let me let me apply for
a job at costco they it looked like do a
good job so across the country owners of
small and large businesses are
recognizing that fair wages and higher
profits go hand in hand it's good for
the bottom line and as America's chief
executive I agree so while Congress
decides what it's going to do and I hope
this year and I'm going to work this
year and urge this year that they
actually pass a law today I'm going to
do what I can to help raise working
Americans wages so today
so today I'm issuing an executive order
requiring federal contractors to pay
their employees a fair wage of at least
ten dollars and ten cents a now
this will make a difference for folks
right now there's a dishwasher at
Randolph Air Force Base in Texas Megan
seven dollars and seventy seven dollars
and seventy six cents an hour 776 an
hour there's a fast food worker at
Andrews right down the street Megan
eight dot 91 sense now there's a laundry
worker at camp dodge in Iowa making nine
dollars and three cents an hour once I
sign this order starting next year as
their contracts come up each of them and
many of their fellow coworkers are going
to get a raise and by the way that
includes folks who get paid in tips
they'll get a raise too
tip wage is gonna have gone up even
slower than the regular minimum wage so
just as it's good for companies across
the country this will be good for
America's bottom line for contractors
and for taxpayers the opponents of the
minimum wage have been using the same
arguments for years and time and again
they've been proven wrong raising the
minimum wage is good for business and
it's good for workers and it's good for
the economy put more money in these
folks pockets that means they got some
money to go shop which in turn means the
business has more customers which means
they may hire more workers and make more
of a profit and let's not forget not
only is it good for the economy it's the
right thing to do there's a simple moral
principle at stake if you take
responsibility and you work as hard as
these folks work if you work full time
you shouldn't be living in poverty not
in America we believe that
and this executive order will cover
americans with disabilities because this
principle doesn't just apply to some of
the surprise to all of us
so I'm going to keep doing whatever I
can to raise working Americans wages and
i would ask any business leader out
there any governor any mayor any local
leader listening do what you can to
raise your employees wages to work to
raise the wages of citizens in your
jurisdiction they'll support these
efforts a majority of Americans not just
Democrats not just independence but
Republicans to support raising the
minimum wage it's the right thing to do
so that's something Congress should keep
in mind this year there is a bill right
now in front of both the House and the
Senate that would boost America's
minimum wage to ten dollars and ten
cents an hour just like I'm doing with
this executive action jeezy remember
1010 1010 let's get that done raise the
federal minimum wage to 1010 wouldn't
just raise wages for minimum wage
workers its effect would lift wages for
about 28 million Americans it would lift
millions of Americans out of poverty
immediately it would help millions more
work their way out of poverty without
requiring a single dollar in new taxes
or spending it's the right thing to do
just last month 600 economists including
seven Nobel Prize winners wrote the
leaders of houses of Congress to remind
them that the bill before Congress would
have little or no negative effect on
hiring on jobs so it's not going to
depress the economy it'll boost the
economy yes it will give more businesses
more customers with more money to spend
it will grow the economy for everybody
so yeah
he's excited about it so members of
Congress have a pretty clear choice to
make right now raise our workers wages
grow our economy or let way to stagnate
further and give workers what amounts to
another pay cut this year restore
unemployment insurance for Americans
still looking for that job or expose
them further to hardship
members of Congress you can help people
make progress in their own lives or you
can hinder that progress and every
American deserves to know where your
elected representative stands on this
issue so ask your senator ask your
representative in the house do you
support raising the federal minimum wage
to 1010 an hour if they say yes tell
them good job you know they don't hear
that that often so give them a pat on
the back give him a hug a lot of no way
to go that's the right thing to do if
they say no be polite I mean don't just
yell at him but but say well why not ask
them to reconsider siding with an
overwhelming majority of Americans
encourage them to say yes give America a
raise so I'm about to sign this
executive order when you hear me talking
about my pen and my phone to make a
difference for middle-class Americans
and those working to get in the middle
class this is exactly what I mean I'm
going to do what I can Congress should
do what it needs to do I will not give
up on this fight no matter how long it
takes America deserves a raise working
families deserve to know some more
economic security in their own lives
we've got to create new jobs strengthen
middle class build new ladders of
opportunity for folks working their way
into the middle class just like these
folks are doing right here there are
millions of Americans who could just use
a little bit of boost millions of
Americans outside of Washington who are
tired of the old stale political
arguments or tired of folks just looking
out for people who can afford big
lobbyists and big campaign contributions
their folks out there who want to see us
restore an economy that works for
everybody and get back to our founding
vision of opportunity for all so I know
you guys will work with me but go out
there and organize some more thank you
everybody let's give
Americans are raised right now I'm in
assignment